[Music]
I work for Hortonworks I've been
involved with Hortonworks there's a lot
of work with the Apache Software
Foundation I'm the founder of a project
called Apache calcite and I'm involved
in a number of other projects as well I
have a long background in the relational
database world I started my career at
Oracle
so I'm unashamedly coming at this from
the perspective of someone who's a
believer in relational database
technology and I'm you know attempting
to convince you that the the good stuff
that relational databases bring is you
know it's it's hard to replicate
you know relational databases and the
idea is the old ideas of relational
databases still have an awful lot to
offer and so you know in my day job I
people people think of calcite as a
query optimizer and this talk is is kind
of talking about what other things that
you can use that technology for and and
I hope this is you know these are
directions that the database world and
the data data engine world will will
travel in and I'm doing my best to make
it happen as part of calcite so yeah
we're going to talk about how you would
tune or how you tune a data system or
how data systems of the future might be
able to tune themselves you know what's
the what's the process of that and what
changes do we need to make to future
systems to make them better some some
folks in the research world are talking
about self-driving databases so I'm
thinking along similar lines this talk
is mainly about our journey in Apache
calcite so various features that we are
have worked on and are working on to
push to push the ball forward but
because it's an open-source project
you know these features will will appear
in other projects and other products
Jack nerdo from Jenny Oh is talking
tomorrow and they're using they're using
calcite
part of this their product and I'm sure
some of these features are appearing in
dreamy oh oh and by the way while I
remember I don't have office hours
scheduled because right after my talk is
the party
so feel free to grab me at the party and
talk but I also drop in on I haven't
asked Jack to this but I'll drop in on
his office hours tomorrow after his talk
and so if you have questions about
calcite or whatever you're welcome to go
and ask them then so this this talk has
two parts that unlike the previous two
of these parts are connected the first
one is just kind of an overview of the
ways that we all that you can organize
the the options that you have for
organizing your data to make your system
run more efficiently and I've got to be
talking a lot about materialized views
because in my opinion they are an
incredibly powerful way of organizing
data and not just the create
materialized views in the broader sense
of well I'll explain but not not not
every materialized view is created using
the create materialized view statement
let's put it that way and then how can
we make system solve organizing so I'll
just I'll discuss some of the strategies
and and work we've done in calcite to
make that happen so first of all
relational algebra this is the kind of
underpins all of this it's based on set
theory and it's mathematically tractable
which makes it super convenient for
building a query optimizer on you you
need the assurance that if you take a
query you can transform it to something
else that something else means the same
as the original query and if you're
lucky it's faster so that's the whole
point of it and so relational algebra is
you know based on mathematics close to
mathematics it's not just relational
these days you can apply relational
algebra to things like nested
collections you know your document
databases that that kind of stuff even
streaming systems
it all basically works so the good thing
and the bad thing about relational
algebra is if you're in order to do
relational algebra you need to have a
declarative language and such a sequel
and you need to have a require optimizer
because relational algebra on its own is
potentially very inefficient the good
news is that once you've written that
query optimizer you get a whole bunch of
other benefits like the ability to add
new storage structures to create new
indexes on your database to add new
algorithms like you might write your
application on the version of the
database that only has nested loops join
and then the next version of the
database has has joy and your
applications will run faster because
they're using the same algorithm even
though you didn't change any of your
code so Apache calcite is an Apache
Apache top level project it's not widely
known because it is not considered to be
an end-user product it is more of like a
library that is used to build data
database systems rather than a database
system itself although it does actually
run as a standalone engine you can
launch it from a single command line and
it does a nice job of doing federated
queries you can kind of compose adapters
to talk to various data sources like CSV
files or Cassandra or MongoDB or Splunk
and you can run queries across across
those data sources but the main purpose
of it is to power the optimizes of
systems like Apache Hiva pachi drill and
recently or like over the last year or
so we've done we've been doing a lot of
work with streaming systems so calcite
is included in the streaming sequel that
is in our chief link apex Apache beam
they're all building streaming sequel
based on that based on calcite and
lastly we use the Apache can be
community development model which
means that we welcome contributions
anyone's welcome to contribute and we
firmly believe in having open discussion
so we develop features in the open so
that you know the development isn't
happening behind closed doors about
development is happening in the open and
anyone can walk up and participate if
they want to so first of all organizing
data so as a motivating example here's a
simple query not actually so simple but
just imagine you have the US Census data
set a hundred million records and 100
gigabytes of data and just imagine you
have it on four Saturdays and you read
you your wreath report is one gigabyte
per second and you want to sum up a
particular field in this data set and
you want the result in under five
seconds the fact is it's a kind of trick
question there is there is no actually
there's no answer it's just just based
on these numbers it's just not possible
to read all that data in under five
seconds so there are various ways that
you can solve this so if you simply just
read all the data sequentially it takes
a hundred seconds one solution you can
do is to buy more Hardware more discs
and more CPUs and spread the data out
across those and and basically because
you have more IO bandwidth you can you
can achieve the result in that time you
could cache the data so you can
basically go out and buy an awful lot
around and if you buy obviously enough
around 100 gigabytes of RAM then your
queries will run very fast but if you
buy ten gigabytes of RAM your data will
your queries will probably run
reasonably fast most of the time and
then you know the data will get kicked
out of RAM and then the next time you
run it it'll take a long time the trick
is and you know this is the solution I'm
advocating is materialize the result if
you simply just want one record of if
you just want one
and you happen to know or happen to
suspect that someone is going to ask
that question you pre compute the answer
and let's take that takes you know eight
bytes of data and it's right there and
you can give the answer immediately and
for a surprisingly large number of
analytic queries those it would be
possible to anticipate that someone is
going to ask that question and so you
know rather than going out and buying a
lot of machines and a lot of memory if
you can be smart and anticipate what the
questions are going to be or if your
system can anticipate what the questions
are going to be then you can you can
achieve these I mean this is if you
materialize you're getting like you know
five orders of magnitude improvement in
running time I mean that is just just
colossal that's much better than you can
achieve by any other means so this is
why it's worth pursuing this this dis
Avenue and then lastly you know if if
you you may not have anticipated all of
the questions you cannot anticipate all
the questions so in my in my view the
the best option is to materialize what
you the questions your anticipate cache
the results because people will
typically have a an interactive session
for 30 minutes where they're asking
questions that have never been asked
before and may never be asked again but
during that 30 minute period they're
working on this particular data set so
you'd like to be able to build these
materializations they're not
materialized views but they are very
similar to that and use those within the
session and then also just to adapt to
spot that people are asking new
questions that haven't been anticipated
so in my opinion the last of these is is
what we ought to be heading for so brief
you overview of all the ways of
organizing data and you know they all
contribute something to to to the
solution so the format you choose is
important the layout I think that I've
seen a couple of talks today talking
about the benefits of column oriented
days
which is certainly useful in you know
reduces the amount of i/o that's done
and then there's also technologies like
arrow which are in memory specialized
for a memory data they happen to be
column oriented but they have some other
features in addition and as we see
things like non-volatile around we may
see new formats coming out that are
specialized for those those in the needs
of those technologies the storage medium
matters a lot you know because the
response time is incredibly different if
it's in memory versus on disk and and if
you have copies of your data perhaps
storing the data in different sort
orders or different partitioning x' if
you know if you need to do a join
between two tables if you happen to
partition them on the same key that's
incredibly helpful your join algorithm
can be a lot more efficient if they're
partitioned on the same key because then
you don't have to shuffle the entire you
know the entire data set from one place
to the other and combinations of the
above my message is that logical
optimizations are the only things that
are capable of producing these orders of
magnitude or multiple orders of
magnitude difference and furthermore the
logical optimizations will if you are
able to provide a logical optimization
like creating materialized view it will
inherit all of the stuff underneath it
so it will inherit the benefits of say
storing your data in aro format okay so
this thing indexes are they were what
made the relational database possible
before indexes were invented you know a
relational database could not do a join
on you know any more than a couple of
hundred rows of data or produce a
reasonable result and I argue an index
is omit a form of materialized view what
I mean by omit to what I mean by a
material
view is a relation which is derived via
some relational algebra that the
optimizer knows about from another from
another relation so a b-tree index is so
here we've got an employee's table and
we've got an index on the department
number of the employees table so the
index really is a table which consists
of two columns the department number and
the name and then it also stores the
ridy so you can go and fetch the rest of
the row the riot e is kind of a virtual
column and the index is very powerful
but it accelerates various kinds of
queries like if you do select count
distinct sorry select distinct order by
depth no it will help with that it can
help with joins and so forth a covering
index is kind of an extension to an
index where it contains not just the not
just the key column and row IDs in fact
instead of storing the varieties you
actually store the other columns on the
table so a covering index is lossless
that in fact it contains the same data
as the table it's just stored in a
different order so if you have covering
indexes
I mean calcite is used by Apache Phoenix
and so Apache Phoenix makes big use of
covering indexes you can very often
rewrite the query so that it it doesn't
hit the base table at all it just is
able to answer the question from the
index so here's the same thing this is
the same the same view as previously the
same relation as previously I've just
changed I've just changed the DDL CIN
text from create cover for create index
to create materialized view so this is
kind of my definition of a materialized
view in the definition and you know the
database research community a data
materialized view is a table that the
that contains the result of a relation
expression so in this case we've got a
table called M spy depth no and and by
the way in in you know in systems like
Oracle I worked in the Oracle kernel
team way back it's kind of a secret that
you know an open secret that an Oracle
index is just underneath the covers is
just a table they use the same libraries
the same data structures and whatever so
MPI depth know is a table and the
optimizer knows that it is it is reading
from the scan of the employees table
followed by a sort in order to and and
so if someone if someone supplies a
query to be evaluated so select from M
ordered by depth note for example the
optimizer now knows that there are two
possible tables that could read and it
knows the relationship between those
tables so the optimizer starts with its
process of searching for a plan with
actually it's got two possible queries
that it could evaluate it knows both
will return the same results and it
tries to find the best plan for the two
queries the one that uses the index and
the one that doesn't when you have
things like joins the it's it's even
more complicated because you've got
combinations that will use the table and
the index and another combination that
we use the table but not the index but
the relational algebra kit problem makes
it possible to tell the optimizer
exactly what it has no more no less
spatial queries spatial data is
something we've been adding to calcite
recently spatial queries are very
interesting because they the normal ways
one organizes data in a relational
database is based on one-dimensional
ranges so a regular b-tree index is
sorted on a particular column it's
possible to sort your data by X&Y simul
taneous li and so conventional index
structures have real problems doing
spatial queries like finding all
restaurants within a particular distance
of a particular point because you can't
sort by latitude and longitude
simultaneously so how to do it there's a
trick in mathematics called the Hilbert
space filling curve in fact is that
there are several space-filling curves
but the Hilbert curve is is one of the
best for these purposes it's a it's a
kind of fractal and what we've got there
are three generations of the
space-filling curve but as you can see
every every point in the plane is on the
curve and by the way it doesn't end at
three we can just care home so any any
given point has a location on the curve
and we can describe that point rather
than saying it's XY coordinates we can
say its distance along the curve from
the bottom left corner and well why
bother with that well then the the
nature is that if two points are close
together in in in geography they are
very likely to be close to each other or
reasonably close to each other on the
space-filling curve not they may not be
I mean you know if there were there
there are two points there which are a
long distance apart but usually you can
if you want to query within a particular
neighborhood you can look at a range or
a small number of ranges on the
space-filling curve so this is that
previous query translated you see you
see on the on the left-hand side we've
added an extra can condition to the
where clause that the hilbert index has
but has to be either between 35 and 40 2
or equal to 46 because that particular
region of the of the
of the of the plane is covered by that
region of the space-filling curve so the
great news is that we can use a
conventional database storage structures
such as an HBase table which is
physically sorted by key and we can just
do a range down on that on that storage
structure so this is this is kind of
tantamount to magic in my opinion you
know the conventional wisdom is that you
know if you want to do special queries
you have to use a specialized data
structure like an artery which most
databases don't have this one we've
basically just transformed in the
optimizer we haven't written any new
algorithms we haven't written any new
data structures we've just transformed
the data in the optimizer into something
that can be very efficiently now there
are some false positives so there are
some regions or there are some points on
that particular range that are not
within one point five units of that of
the of our current location so we still
keep the esti distance predicate that
still gets evaluated but we really have
very few polls false positives so this
this query is much more efficient than
the previous one and then the final step
is to tell the optimizer about this so
that it can do it automatically and we
do this by just providing metadata in
our DDL so we've added this column H to
the table we've told it that it's
generated it's a generated column it's
generated and stored so when you insert
a record it automatically populates that
this H value and we've also asked it to
sort the table by this column so the
table now is now physically sorted by
age and so we can do we can do a range
scan and by the way we could have used a
check constraint that would have worked
just as well
streaming is another area that you may
be surprised can benefit from
materialized views so as I said earlier
we've we've been doing a lot of work in
calcite on streaming sequel streaming is
becoming important because a lot of data
is I think you know Kafka has helped
accelerate this process but a lot of
data is you know data in motion a lot of
the most valuable data is data which is
incredibly recent because a lot of data
types a lot of kinds of data decrease in
value very rapidly
you know like stock tips and so forth
they they you know they're useless if
you don't act on them and this data is
Kafka has again made people realize that
this data is more often than not
inherently relational so I would claim
stream queries are great but hybrid
streaming and relational queries are
even better so you know the top one is a
streaming query from orders we're
interested in a continuously execute
inquiry every time we receive an order
that's more than a thousand units tell
me so you can think of this as reading
from a Kafka topic and writing to
another Kafka topic continuously the
historic query is also on the orders
relation but we're interested in stuff
that happened you know 18 months ago so
I claim that it's useful to be able to
consider orders as both a stream so
future orders and present orders but
also in the past and it's very
convenient to have to be able to refer
to it as a single relation name as
opposed to say well this is where you go
for recent orders and this is where you
go for orders between you know one week
and two weeks old and this is where you
go for old orders I claim it's it's
nicer to be able to say just orders and
the system figures that way to go for it
so and here's a here's a query which
actually uses both of them together
we're interested in orders which are
bigger than the average size of orders
for the
particular product so combining a stream
combining the future with the past and I
claim that this thing the average the
average order size for each product that
is a kind of materialized view we'd like
the system to just keep such table in
memory or something like that and just
keep it up to date and you don't go off
to HDFS and keep on scanning HDFS just
just keep keep a copy of the data in in
memory so they so I can apply this
filter we would there's no system that
does that today but we would like
systems of the future to be able to do
that and materialized view is how you
how you would model something like that
so in short materialized views are in my
opinion in my biased opinion the the the
finest form of data optimization or at
least the one we should be concentrating
a lot of resources on and it applies to
a lot of different areas so now the
question is okay these are great
optimizations who's going to design
these materializations is it going to be
the user or is it going to be you know
is the system going to help so obviously
our goal of having these
materializations is to impute improve
response time system throughput in other
words do do more with fewer resources
and perhaps we can also compress the
data and just spend less money on
storage again to achieve the same you
know the desired results
but the matter goal is that we would
like these optimizations to be
predictable we don't want a query to run
fast on Monday and slow on Tuesday we
would like them we would like these
things to be adaptive it's it's no good
that you run a query the system on
Monday which is incredibly slow the
system learns that about that query on
Tuesday and then on Wednesday the query
is fast because we
the user has finished doing that their
analysis so we would like the system to
adapt by even on short-term timescales
and we would also like to allow human
intervention because humans you know
database administrators and so forth do
quite often know best so today the way
systems learn is a human looks at them
and goes well that sucks
you know we why didn't we put an index
on this table that's that's the way
systems learn these days they adapt to a
certain extent I mean cash is a very
simple and effective way of making the
system adaptive the cash fills up and
then the query the query runs faster but
we should be introducing smart
algorithms we should be using machine
learning techniques and and and whatever
to make this stuff work better so some
example adaptations I've mentioned cache
already but adding adding things like
indexes and changing the data
organization so I'm gonna describe some
of some of the well this is this is the
vision of where I'd like us to go this
is kind of for an analytic system you
know imagine something like tableau
which is doing interactive query
slice-and-dice queries what you do what
you'd like to see is where the data is
on disk and as far as you know as far as
far as you the analysts know you're
writing your report you believe you're
just addressing tables but as you're
writing this query materializations you
know summaries of this data are being
written into memory perhaps some of
those pre-designed that some of them are
happening on the fly and so as these as
these data sets which might be you know
these aren't just cache blocks but these
are joins between tables
you know partial aggregates on these on
these tables they're loaded into memory
and the next time you access that
particular part of the data set
suppose you're you know you've just Anna
query on on profitability for products
in March that data set will be in memory
and the system will use that that in
memory data for the March part of the
query but you're also asking for April
so it will go to disk for April and have
this work all through all through sequel
rather than your OLAP your you know
slice and dice bi tool having to be
smart about it that's where I'd like I'd
like this to go the process of building
materialized views is incredibly complex
so we have to in order for this to work
six things have to happen and each of
them is incredibly complicated so
someone has to figure out which
materializations need to be created or
something some algorithm somebody needs
to populate them
somebody needs to when the underlying
data changes somebody needs to
incrementally populate them they need to
be used so the the the end-user doesn't
know the existence of these
materializations perhaps because they
just came into being so you should write
your queries against the base table and
the optimizer needs to rewrite the
queries to use them it needs to adapt so
that as new queries are written on new
parts of the data set are accessed new
materializations come into being and
then we need to rich expressive language
so not just materializations for let's
say summary queries but also for spatial
queries and streaming and other
application areas as well so I'm going
to describe summary tables how to do
this for summary tables but this kind of
process could happen on other other
patterns of data as well so in calcite
we have this disk structure called a
lattice which is really a way of saying
it's incredibly different it's kind of
not even tractable to design
materialized views are that are going to
work for join aggregate queries because
it's just so difficult to recognize
queries that the pattern matching is
just too great a search space so we have
this data structure called a lattice
which basically you tell the system this
is the star schema this is I've got a
central fact table called sales and it
joins to a customer's table via this
product foreign key time dimension table
a product table and and then there's a
snowflake the product table joins to the
product class table so you tell the
system that this star schema exists and
it starts watching for queries that use
a subset of those tables along those
join paths and calcite is able to create
materialized views create summary tables
for particular combinations of
attributes so for example in this
particular example it's it's grouping by
state and zipcode year year state and
zipcode there might be another one which
is by quarter and city or something like
that so the lattice gives it kind of a
hint about what join paths it should be
looking for so the search space even
free even for a star schema with you
know twenty or thirty attributes is
still pretty phenomenal because if
you've got thirty attributes there's two
to the thirty combinations of summary
tables you could create and so let me
explain what this is so the letters are
Z stands for zip code s stands for state
G stands for gene
so these you can think of each of these
ellipses here as a possible group by
clause if I was to say let's look at the
the one nearest me so if we were to
group by state gender year and month we
get six thousand records back because of
the number of distinct values of those
attributes if we group by nothing then
we'll just get one record will go to get
the grand total so so in order to be
able to generate an optimal set of
summary tables we need to know ahead of
time how many rows each summary table
will have it's rearranged as a lattice
because if I happen to have computed a
summary table by a gender and year then
I can roll up and compute group a year
or raw egg or compute group by gender so
so this is the kind of thing we'd like
the algorithm to produce you know if we
decide to if we decide to create the G
comma Y one we don't need to create the
G because we can we can compute that
very easily we can roll up ten rows into
two rows there is an existing algorithm
for this the design summary tables it's
well established in in the in the
literature and calcite has an
implementation of it but the problem was
we need data I actually I'm gonna skip
over this but we did it we did it turns
out to be a really difficult problem to
gather enough statistics for those two
to the 30 attributes to know which which
summary tables are likely to be
interesting so calcite 1616 was devising
ways of kind of doing analyzed table
compute statistics on a huge scale and
computing
combinations of attributes many
combinations of attributes all at the
same time okay then the last graph the
last question is you know end users
don't like writing these lattices so the
question is is it possible to create
lattices automatically to figure out
you've got a database which is populated
by you know 30 tables is it possible to
figure out which tables are used in
combination with each other in other
words wire the star scheme is inside
that database and so we've this this
syntax the alter schema infer lattices
doesn't exist but the algorithm to infer
the lattices does so basically we have a
component inside calcite it's actually
it's not committed yet but it's under
it's under development which looks at
queries and did uses it sees a one query
that joins sales to the customers table
another query that joins to the sales to
the product table merges of them them
together and deduces that this is
probably a star schema and this is worth
something what's worth watching and
creating summary tables over no it's
it's it's actually housed many candidate
lattices are all in memory at the same
time but over time if a particular
lattice isn't is either superseded by
another one or doesn't seem to be used
very much it'll kill it off so to
summarize making systems learn is a
combination of you know human effort
manual tuning addict short-term kind of
automatic kind of reflexive adaptations
like kind of thing Akash does plus
adding smart algorithms to make database
this kind of self tuning in order to
design summary tables
we have to draw together query history
so what what queries we've seen we have
to look at the shape of the data the
number of distinct values of various
columns and pulling all of that stuff
together we can produce summary tables
we've been talking about some summary
tables here but there are other kinds of
materialized views that would benefit
just as much from this kind of approach
and yeah a relational algebra is you
know as important forever
there's over so that's all I have are
there any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
the the space-filling hilbert curve how
do you calculate the the like the
min/max boundaries on on the curve is
there a closed-form calculation for that
or you have to do something recursive by
the min and Max you mean what's the
minimum value of the the the index along
the curve yes yeah I mean the examples I
had there were you know one of them said
it was a valley between 1 and 64 it's
that I was cheating a little I mean the
nicer way of thinking about it is it's a
fraction between 0 and 1 and so you know
if you are the bottom the bottom left
corner is 0 and the bottom right corner
is 1 and so you know it's it's it's
always a fraction between 0 and 1 and if
you want to go you know depth 4 then
it's going to have 8 bits if you want to
go depth you know 16 you're gonna have
32 bits so it's a fraction it's zero
point and then a you know a binary
string after it so the short answer your
question is it's always between 0 and 1
and does the so in your example you had
you know XY coordinates that you were
fitting onto onto the curve does it
generalize to you know to n number of
dimensions yes it does
I think if you go to you know really
high numbers of dimensions it loses
locality but you you know you can very
you can very easily go to three or four
dimensions and yeah it's a it's a pretty
effective dimension reduction technique
I think for Leah let's say for 2 3 4
dimensions I think it starts running out
of steam beyond that but it's that's
still good enough to to do you know
things like finding collisions and CAD
diagrams that kind of stuff
thank you so in your opinion the
materialized view is more the savings
coming further with using the IO of the
data engine or is reducing a computation
it if it I always the case would it be
make actually also made a lot of sense
to focus on cashing the data block in a
memory it's possible well the cool thing
about materialized views is it's a it
allows the optimizer to to to realize
there are other algorithms that could
use okay it could it could use another
data set and it could use another
possible algorithm so if you've written
a table that has very good io
characteristics for sequential scans
then and your data some of you have a
copy of your data in that table then you
you will get the full benefit of that so
you apply materialized we rewrite it now
takes one query now produces three and
just says go ahead optimizer find the
best you know the the best
implementation of a B or C based on io
cost and and you should tell the tell
the optimizer what your you know what
the IO cost is for your particular table
type so you'll get you'll get full
benefit of it but there may there may be
some things your table is not particular
your table may not be very good at
random access for example in which case
even though the summary table exists the
optimizer will just choose to use the
regular table because it knows it's
going to be a lot of random access so
it's a it's a win-win situation
yeah even though I work for a company
which is you know what works does Hadoop
I think we lost a lot because you know
Hadoop came along and the the the
message was we can solve all problems
with brute force
you know we your data's on the thousand
nodes of course your queries are going
to be fast but it's you know it's using
a lot of power and there are a lot of
cases where you can you can solve
problems just by being smart you know
not necessarily just by going you know
by using by using scale
[Music]